[Musik]
halo legends of sales gerade fertig
sparkurs zeit und wir mögen spatel
eigentlich ganz gerne
wir sind auch der spanier ist der
spargel regierung gibt sich spanische
sparkurs straße die istrische wiesental
und 36 das erstmal entlang und links für
stück badische schwarz sparkurs straße
genommen und bei uns gibt's wie gesagt
ganz viel spargel und heute gibt's einen
flammkuchen einmal mit grünem und einmal
mit weißem sparte und ich finde
flammkuchen ganz perfekt denn schnell
zubereitet ist genau man keine auf den
punkt vorbereiten und mit freunden und
gut essen vor allem wenn man einen
flammkuchen open hat im garten doch auch
ganz treuen freunde vor
das haben wir ja bei uns haben leider
noch nicht auf vielleicht irgendwann ja
auch mal oder noch etwas vom kuchen
genau ob er ist warum haben sie haben ja
manchmal dass erstmals ein und dann ist
andere gehört jedenfalls zeige ich euch
jetzt einfach mal die paten für den
flammkuchen zeigt und später dann die
zutaten für den ballack für den hefeteig
brauche ich 240 liter lauwarmes wasser
anhalten dürfte eine prise zucker 410
gramm mehl 2 teelöffel salz und drei
assists zu lesen in den titeln jetzt
auch mit den händen verkneten ich mache
das ist allerdings mit der
küchenmaschine meist schneller und
einfacher geht und jetzt beide hände
frei gebe ich zuerst einmal das wasser
hefe erstmals hinauf
[Musik]
es kommen noch mehl und salz mir das so
und auch gleich oliven und dann wieder
fünf minuten geschmeidig getötet
[Musik]
der teig fertig jetzt nehme ich ein
bisschen mehr für die arbeitsfläche
darauf freue mich ihn hier zu einer
tristen bands
[Musik]
oft gibt es ein bisschen medien
geschüttelt dann wind hinein
jetzt denke ich den tag ab und lassen so
abgedeckt für eine stunde auf gehen der
teig ist aufgegangen jetzt gebe ich
ihnen auf die arbeitsfläche und werden
in vier portionen und ein teil des lamm
kuchen
[Musik]
ich war mit jede partie zu einer kugel
und troll wieder mond oder oval für mich
aus
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt ein paar früher das
backblech und west einem sportverein
gesprächen mit wachstums- und wer gibt
hier den teig drauf und schlägt ihn
jetzt ganz kurz zu machen noch
defensiven werte
[Musik]
früher gemacht wurde
als das feuer im ofen angeheizt
dabei hat auch die flamme da und daher
hat es den namen in die flammen
denn um beim aufheizen
die energie zu verwenden bis später eben
das gros drin gewesen sei habe ich jetzt
schon ausgerollt jetzt kommt der belag
dran
dafür mache ich jetzt eine variation mit
weißem spargel und eine variation mit
grünem spargel ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten für den weißen spargel
flammenkuchen brauch ich 20 gramm
bärlauch 250 gramm cocktailtomaten und
200m schwanz und für die grüne variante
brauche ich 200 gramm schwanz 150 gramm
räucherlachs hier habe ich 250 gramm
grüne spargel und natürlich halten wir
fangen jetzt mit der grünen variante
teilzunehmen den schwanz da kommt
beziehungsweise pfeffer rein
ich kann den spargel nehmen und den in
zwei bis 2 5 zentimeter lange stücke
schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt macht die hälfte hier und die
hälfte drauf
[Musik]
ich fange jetzt hier schon mit dem
runden an und belegten jetzt einfach mit
grünem spargel und dann auch mit im lack
[Musik]
ja
und so warten die flammkuchen jetzt vor
verletzten backofen bei 42 grad ober
unterhitze in der unteren einschub
leiste für etwa 10 bis 15
weiter geht's mit dem weißen spargel
jetzt nehme ich den schwanz beißt auch
wieder erlaubt mir das so
der schmeckt wunderbar ersparte sich mal
mach mal so und findet so püriert
[Musik]
das kloster verteilen und ich sehe in
der zeit zu sparen
[Musik]
der spargel mir das bein gehoben
das mache ich es hier mit der hupe ihr
könnt aber auch dafür die maschine
benutzen
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir auch den weißen
spargel hier drauflegen und automaten
ganz ohne chance kerner schon gesagt
[Musik]
das long chor ist schon fertig den nehme
ich aus dem auto deshalb fliegender
wechsel vorsicht ganzheit und der
nächste kann wieder in den ofen
[Musik]
so möchte zu schneiden wir probiert
schon mal die eine worte was ich schreib
mal an und trug beim pflanzen für die
meinungen 180 macht beim fahren mit
leuten und manche ein bisschen
lächerlich macht
da kommst hast du super gemacht ich
mache es den rest okay von ihrer klasse
mannschaft ganz toller ja wenn will mich
auch wenn sie dorthin zurückbringen die
her geboten
oliver morath ecke oder mittels lang
warum muss man auch sofort essen
da wird schon schnell und langsam nichts
belegen er feiern haben die polycom
liegt mit 9 8 führung mit dem knackigen
spargel richtig lecker aber auf jeden
fall jetzt schon um ein favorit jetzt
warten wir noch sieben minuten auf den
anderen
natürlich beginnt er ist genauso wie
über alles fleisch essen solange er noch
vermisst jetzt warten wir noch auf die
weiße variante wo wären wir auch bei
euch ja schon gesagt ob es glaubt auf
türkisch nicht eine frage aber keine
weiße thomas
die tomaten und erdbeeren muss ehrlich
sagen sie mir gefallen eine grüne
schweine verendet besser deswegen auch
richtig gut vor allem mit dem bärlauch
bärlauch kann mir auch selber ran muss
nur aufpassen
worauf muss man aufpassen sammeln von
bärlauch moral
womit kann man in verwechseln das muss
in dieser vision ist ja der punkt geht
an andrea dass man sie nicht verwechselt
mit maiglöckchen weil sie sehen gleich
aus aber da muss man einfach dran rufen
zum riechen und wenn für knoblauch
ähnlich riecht dann eben nicht irgendwo
im wald und nicht wieder los geht
einfach nicht in valence kenne meine
mama hat welche nehm ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher jedenfalls finde ich auch
diesen flammkuchen richtig lecker und
falls ihr euch entscheiden kannst du wie
ich dann mach doch auch einfach weiter
variationen in grün und weiß
und falls ihr das rezept nachlesen wo es
geht auf facebook blogs das stets noch
mal ganz genau
die sparkasse war und macht spargel
flammkuchen und noch viele andere
rezepte also viel spaß gemacht haben und
bis zum nächsten mal schön fühlte ich
wusste doch das war noch keine tomaten
macht's gut
[Musik]
mai
nein
[Musik]
jetzt frage ich dich aber mal wie was
kam zuerst des monats muss warum und wie
kommt es nach dem 11
draußen ein schlüpfen das kam es zuerst
das huhn oder das ei dann schlüpfen
kannst doch nicht sein dass ich zuerst
aber war und woher kommt mutter und
vater hohen ja aber wie kommen sie auf
die welt
also wenn du deine antwort darauf hin
dass bei mir rabanne staaten zu deinen
eigenen youtube kanal ok kannst du mal
noch ein bisschen was erforschen und die
lösung finden
okay das ist jetzt ganz viele andere
auch den tipp dass viele menschen aus
aller welt wenn nicht warum salami wie
ihr alle wisst alle balla balla balla
balla balla balla fackeln auf dem löffel
sprache
sprache hallo
[Musik]